bonsoir marielle de sarnez merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes ministre chargé des
affaires européennes candidate aussi aux
législatives on en parlera après premier
conseil des ministres de ce gouvernement
comme le disait françois bayrou comme on
en parle qui reste extrêmement atypique
qui correspond à la promesse peut-être
d'emmanuel macro mais dont on attend
avec beaucoup de curiosité le
fonctionnement mais d'abord froid qui
correspond aussi pas seulement à la
promesse d' emmanuel macron me
correspond à ce qu'attendent les
français au fond confusément depuis
longtemps à sortir de cette espèce de
pot position absolument stérile entre
des gens qui souvent pensent la même
chose mais qui s'opposent parce qu'ils
sont pas dans le même camp et ça a donné
quoi ça a donné des années des années
des années des puissances publiques
totales de promesses non tenues dont
fera que c'est sale attente des français
et il y avait un moment c'était émouvant
pour moi c'est la première fois toute ma
vie je suis ministre dont j'en suis très
heureuse en plus c'est l'europe donc
c'est ce qu'il faut ce en quoi je crois
complètement fortement profondément
c'était très émouvant et en même temps
il y avait une équipe qui était très
compacte c'est à dire c'est très
cohérent les gens qui sont là oui ok il
ya des gens dans les centrales
thermiques être pris les caisses comme
différence entre on va dire jean yves le
drian gérard collomb d'un côté
finalement edouard fini pour bruno le
maire de l'autre y en a peut-être pour
qui tel ou tel sujet c'est plus
intéressant mais au fond ils partagent
tous la même vision sont tous
profondément européen
ils pensent tous qu'il faut davantage de
liberté pour les entreprises davantage
de liberté pour l'économie en même temps
ils savent qu'il faut de la solidarité
et qu'il faut aider ceux qui ont le plus
de difficulté ils savent que l'école
c'est fondamental et qu'il faut la
réformer pour que ça marche mieux et ils
savent qu'il faut des réformes de fofana
et freedom exemptant les six n'ont
jamais été fait
oui mais sur ces informations prendre
bruno le maire les républicains lui dise
bas pendant votre programme des
primaires vous disiez qu'il fallait
baisser la csg maintenant vous allez la
faire augmenter à oui mais ça c'est le
problème d embrigadement de partys vous
voulez moi je suis une femme à ses
livres donc j'essaye au fond d'avoir mes
propos cités où mes propres convictions
en même temps c'est assez courageux
quand vous avez tenu la position de
battre parties de prendre quand même le
risque de se dire écoutez là c'est un
moment
qui est un moment important c'est un
moment clé pour le pays moi je pense que
c'est
nous avons une obligation de réussir je
pense vraiment que c'est la dernière
chance pour le pays avant de tomber
peut-être dans l'extrémisme si nous ne
réussissons pas oui et donc au fond ça
nécessite de dépasser des escales dont
sera donné du coup le président et
quelques elle quelle méthode quelle
feuille de route
comment ça va fonctionner comme ça va
très bien fonctionné parce que c'est
cohérent très bien fonctionné il ya un
projet et à ce qu apporte emmanuel
macron pendant la campagne
c'est un jeune président moi je trouve
que c'est une promesse pour la france
formidable je pense que sa présidence va
faire du bien au pays
je pense que peut-être la france a la
chance là de sortir d'une espèce de
dépression finalement que nous vivons
depuis des années et des années
alors oui ya beaucoup d'attentes
beaucoup d'attentes parce qu'il n'ya pas
de lien de grâce vous avez vu les semer
ses biens montre je le dis il ya moins
de gens qui sont invaincus que dans
n'importe quelle élection présidentielle
d'abord moi je trouve ça très bien
qu'ils aient pas d'état de grâce c'est
d'ailleurs un terme ça veut dire quoi et
à grasse c'est à dire c'est un moment où
pourrait faire tout et n'importe quoi
que ça trouveraient grâce aux yeux de
tout le monde ça veut dire que les
français sont exigeants oui ça me dit
que les français ils attendent des
réponses avec les français ils ont pas
seulement des attentes pas seulement des
espoirs aussi quelquefois ils expriment
évidemment de la désarroi du désarroi de
la colère mais il ya une attente et
c'est ça que je trouve très intéressant
pour l'espagnol mais justement là par
exemple quand il va y avoir la réforme
du code du travail la réforme de la
moralisation de la vie publique mais
mais surtout les réformes
on va revenir on va venir sur l'europe
bien sûr dans l'instant parce que tout
ça est quand même lié mais quand il ya
la réforme du code du travail ou bien
des réformes dans l'éducation et qu'il
ya des gens dans la rue parce que ils
sont pas contents qu'est ce qui se passe
d'abord je crois qu'on a on avance comme
ça des phrases à quoi ça va servir cette
réforme du code du travail
ça va servir à donner plus au fond
peut-être de liberté à ce qui peut
décider dans le cadre de l'entreprise
c'est à dire à faire davantage confiance
aux terrains à ce qu'ils font à ceux qui
savent bien écoutez c'est bien
franchement dans la plupart des pays qui
nous entourent
en europe ça se passe de cette façon là
il ya en france peut-être une espèce de
2 sur administration quelquefois il faut
st
cliff y est évidemment il faut protéger
il faut sécuriser
il faut garantir mais en même temps il
faut libérer
il faut donner aux chefs d'entreprise
voilà une possibilité peut-être d'aller
plus loin d'aller plus vite c'est
important pour l'emploi aussi demain en
france elle ne s'en est dit a eu deux
candidats qui sont arrivés au premier
tour jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen
qui avait un regard très sceptique sur
l'europe et sur l'euro
soyons clairs vous êtes ministre de
l'europe évidemment il est il a obtenu
66 % au deuxième tour mais ces électeurs
là ils sont restés toujours aussi
sceptique sur l'europe comment vous
allez faire bien pour leur expliquer
qu'on peut qu'on peut réformer l'europe
est à mon sens de réponse
la première c'est que la france commence
enfin fallait réforme qu'elle doit faire
c'est que ça commence à aller mieux
c'est que peut-être on renoue avec la
croissance c'est qu'on recrée des
possibilités d'emploi qu'on facilite
co-favoris qu'on assouplissent ça c'est
extrêmement important qu'on fasse les
réformes par exemple pour l'école vous
en parliez tout à l'heure avec luc ferry
mais je dire que 40 % d'élèves qui
rentrent aujourd'hui en sixième sans
maîtriser totalement la lecture et
l'écriture mais c'est un crime on peut
pas rester indifférent à ça donc ça il
faut le changer de toute urgence parce
qu'après tous ces jeunes qu'est ce
qu'ils deviennent pas des jeunes au
chômage quand ils sortent du système
éducatif
donc ça c'est la première chose que la
france au fonds fasse ce qu'elle a à
faire
quel enfin qu'elle gagne et qu'elles
reviennent en force et si elle revient
en force
il ya bien évidemment à ce moment là
dans un destin dans une vision
européenne on pèsera à nouveau dans
l'europe et moi ce que j'aimerais mais
profondément c'est réconcilier les
français avec concilier tous les
français avec l'idée européenne
et même si josi avec l'idéal européen
qu'est ce que c'est l'idée européenne
c'est que des citoyens librement de
peuples différents ont consenti
consentent à défendre ensemble des
intérêts parce qu'ils pensent que
ensemble on sera le plus avant
simplement il faut que cette europe
il faudra qu'on la voit là il faudra
qu'on la change faudra qu'elle se des
technocrates is vous voyez ce que je
veux dire on dit l'europe c'est beau
c'est d'abord l'europe c'est pas une
affaire politique étranger à l'europe
c'est nous pas bruxelles que ça explose
dans les ministères de l'europe il
semble hélas ça veut dire que le
président emmanuel macron mais l'europe
au coeur ils l'assument 10 et
aujourd'hui ces ministères de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères et donc c'est
formidable nous avons un destin commun
en europe mais moi il faut qu'on
construise tous tous une europe qui nous
qui nous aide qui sécurise qui protège
est ce qu'il ya un an défendre et la
merkel elle a dit au début c'est magique
mais après on attend les résultats si
elle va pas nous mener de cadeaux oui
mais personne ne fera de cadeau à
personne mais en même temps on va on a
je crois
recréer une confiance avec l'allemagne
l'europe elle a toujours avancé quand la
france et l'allemagne ont décidé de la
faire avancer ensemble mais ça ne peut
se faire que si on est des partenaires
qui s'estiment et qui se respecte des
deux côtés un et lapins qui doit être
plus fort les deux doivent être forts
donc la première chose c'est que la
france fasse ce qu'elle a à faire son
propre boulot l'éducation nationale
c'est pal europe 1 le problème de notre
déficit de nos dettes d'améliorer les
choses pour tous ceux qui créent de
l'emploi demain c'est pas l'europe ça
c'est la france
il faut le faire et il faut redonner de
l'espoir pour l'europe il faut entendre
moi je vais entendre ce qu'ils disent de
nos concitoyens que l'europe elle
apparaît lointaine elle apparaît
technocratique
elle nous protège pas je sais pas habile
à vis des importations de certains pays
sur les travailleurs détachés comme ça
et qu'on règle les problèmes si vous
êtes optimiste avait l'impression qu'on
pourra obtenir des résultats par exemple
sur les travailleurs détachés il faut se
battre
1 il faut qu'on entende d'abord ce que
les français ont à dire est ce que la
france a dit apprendre décide pas tout
seul on décidera à 27
et donc il faut pouvoir porter ces
dossiers avoir une force de conviction
entendre les arguments des autres pays
mais en même temps que les autres pays
comprennent que il ya des situations
auxquelles oui il faut mettre
il faut mettre fin dans ces législatives
où vous êtes candidat dans une
circonscription dans le 11e
circonscription de paris il ya devant
vous le socialiste pascal cherki aussi
un républicain aujourd'hui francis
szpiner qui est devenu candidat vous
vous les candidats dans marche 10
il faut donner une
une majorité au président mais d'autres
disent maintenant il faut donner une
opposition républicaine et pas seulement
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon il
faut qu'une certaine façon les autres
partis demeure et des républicains
qu'ils soient pas dans les extrêmes
comme vous dites mais vous voyez bien
que les deux parties on va dire parti
socialiste d'un côté républicain de
l'autre ce sont des partis qui arrive en
fin de cycle
ce sont des partis qui sont traversés
par des clivages absolument énorme
qu'est ce qui est commun entre les
frondeurs super à gauche qui regardent
surtout pas l'économie le monde qui
détestent l'entreprise et les
sociaux-démocrates ouvert et
progressiste qu'est ce qui est commun
entre une droite on va dire républicaine
modérée et une droite anti européenne à
fond rien donc on voit bien que ces deux
clivages à droite et à gauche voilà il
30 il passe par ces deux partis étaient
au fond il va y avoir une re composition
vous pensez avoir la majorité absolue
oui je pense que les français donneront
sa chance à ce gouvernement je pense que
les français donneront sa chance au
nouveau président de la république pour
agir pour faire parce qu'au fond qu'est
ce qu'on entend des deux autres partis c
est en particulier d'une toute petite
partie de la droite parce qu'en fait il
y en a beaucoup qui soutiennent un qui
soutiennent le nouveau président une
partie de la droite dit ah non non faut
pas voter pour emmanuel macron faut
l'empêcher d'agir d'une certaine manière
ne lui donnez pas vos votes et vos
suffrages
ben oui empêcher d'agir c'est pas la
réponse empêcher d'agir ça fait des
années qu'on empêche d'agir là pour une
fois on a une chance mais je dois je la
crois vraiment historique je fais les
choses historique d'avancé en france de
redonner de la confiance de redonner de
l'espoir et de la solidarité pour la
france et pour l'europe
et moi je suis sûr que cette chance les
français vont la saisir merci merci
marielle de sarnez est revenue sur notre
plateau bon week-end à tous